étoile récente laisse à penser très
sérieusement que la croissance est
essoufflée fin 2022 pourquoi on le sait
en raison de l'impact de l'inflation et
de la hausse des taux d'intérêt sur la
demande des ménages et des entreprises
la prévision de 1% du gouvernement pour
2023 supposerait par conséquent une
accélération de l'activité au cours de
l'année
disons-le pour être tout à fait objectif
cette hypothèse ne peut pas être exclue
compte tenu des récents signaux
relativement positifs montrant une
certaine résilience de l'économie
française l'emploi demeure dynamique le
risque une rupture des
approvisionnements en électricité en gaz
par est désormais limité pour les
prochains mois donc Clément les tensions
sur les prix l'énergie s'atténue depuis
l'été le ralentissement des commis
allemandes et plus généralement de la
zone euro apparaît moins prononcé
qu'anticiper au début l'automne notre
partenaire allemand devrait pouvoir
éviter une récession en 2023
néanmoins le Conseil continue de
considérer que le CN croissance du Grand
est toujours optimiste l'environnement
international demeure tout de même
défavorable en 2023 alors même que le
durcissement des politiques monétaires
devraient poursuivre madame lacarde
l'annoncer en réalité la vente-hier
notamment dans la zone euro et sa
contribuerait à freiner la demande au
cours des prochains trimestres
l'investissement pourrait notamment
partir de là hausse plus forte quantité
des taux d'intérêt dans la zone euro
dans un contexte d'incertitude élevé et
de fait même si nous avons des nouvelles
relativement bonne plutôt moins mauvaise
que prévu la prévision de croissance du
gouvernement se situe au dessus de
l'ensemble des prévisions des acides
conjoncture français internationaux
ainsi que du consensus des économistes
qui en janvier
anticipe une croissance des colonies
françaises de seulement 0,2% en 2023 la
Banque de France est à 0,3 vous le savez
le Conseil considère par conséquent que
la prévision de croissance qui est
annexée à ce projet reste élevé elle est
justifiée par le gouvernement par la
résilience française au troisième
trimestre 2022 et par là qu'il
croissance sur 2023 elle sous-estime à
nos yeux cependant les facteurs de
freinage de l'activité qui sont
actuellement à l'oeuvre notamment le
niveau élevé de l'inflation et le
durcissement des politiques monétaires
le gouvernement prévoit également
toujours pour 2023 une hausse de
l'indice des prix de consommation de
4,2% moyenne annuel après une
progression de 5,2 en 2022
les prévisions d'inflation restent
dépendantes évolution des prix
énergétiques qu'il est aujourd'hui
difficile d'anticiper la fin de la
remise carburant au 31 décembre 2022 la
revalorisation de 15% en moyenne des
tarifs réglementés du gaz au 1er janvier
et l'électricité 1er février sont à
court terme des facteurs de hausse alors
que les baisses récentes des prix des
marchés du gaz du pétrole ont à
l'inverse un effet clairement baissier
notre jugement est que le reflux
anticipé par le gouvernement de
l'inflation semble néanmoins rapides
cette prévision d'inflation pour 2023
elle est elle aussi plus faible que la
moyenne du consensus des économistes
plutôt la croissance n'est plus forts là
c'est plus faible on est toujours pas
dans le consensus le consensus est à 4,8
elle suppose un nette infléchissement
par rapport aux tendances récentes or
l'indexation du SMIC et les hausses de
salaire déjà négociés ainsi que la
hausse des prix de production et
d'importation au prix des produits
alimentaires et manufacturés devraient
continuer à soutenir l'inflation en 2023
c'est ce que disent notamment vous le
savez
responsable de la grande distribution au
vu de ces éléments le Haut Conseil
considère que la prévision d'inflation
retenue pour 2023 est un peu faible
le gouvernement a également maintenu sa
prévision d'une progression de ma
salariale des branches marchands non
agricoles 5% en 2023 sa prévision de
croissance du salaire moyen nous paraît
faible en lien notamment avec la
sous-estimation des perspectives
d'inflation parce que sans qu'il y ait
d'indexation il y a tout de même un
rapport et si l'inflation était plus
élevée alors on peut anticiper des
hausses de salaire un peu plus élevées
également l'eau Conseil estime donc que
la prévision de ma salariale pour 2023
est un peu basse en résumé
sur ce premier message le Conseil estime
que la prévision de croissance pour 2023
est élevé qu'en revanche la prison de
d'inflation est un peu basse tout comme
celle de la masse salariale
j'entre maintenant dans le détail des
constats du FCP concernant les finances
publiques sur la base de cette saisine
que je l'ai dit nous jugeons clairement
trop étroites le hcfp est chargé
d'évaluer le réalisme des recettes et
des dépenses du pépère 16 qui vous est
présenté veiller à la cohérence de ce
texte avec les orientations
pluriannuelles de finances publiques sur
ce dernier point il y a une évidence qui
est que la loi organique ne permet pas
au hcfp de se prononcer car le projet de
LPF de loi de programmation de finance
publique présentée par le gouvernement
n'a pas à ce stade était adopté ceci me
donne l'occasion d'insister c'est à dire
lourdement parce que je crois que c'est
important sur un message que j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de présenter au Parlement
et que le HCF a repris dans son avis la
France ne peut pas se passer d'une loi
de programmation des finances publiques
c'est une obligation juridique qui est
organique qui est européenne mais c'est
surtout et avant tout un instrument de
pilotage indispensable des finances
publiques l'érosion progressive de la
position des finances publiques de la
France au sein de l'euro les
investissements publiques massifs
auxquels notre pays fait face nécessite
de redresser nos comptes publics pour y
parvenir ce qu'est tout à fait
atteignable sans recourir à l'austérité
comme le montre de nombreux exemples
européens l'effort doit évidemment être
piloté sur plusieurs années pour être
réaliste et pour préserver le potentiel
de croissance de l'économie c'est
pourquoi je le redis nous avons besoin
d'une telle programmation plus annuelle
et je me permets puisque je suis devant
la route assemblée d'appeler toutes les
parties prenantes à faire en sorte que
la France se dote d'une telle loi de
programmation et ces deux que possible
je ne veux pas m'étendre là-dessus je ne
veux pas être alarmiste trop
c'est pas mon rôle en plus mais son
absence pose de nombreux problèmes
juridiques les problèmes politiques des
problèmes de pilotage donc il serait
vraiment dangereux de sous-estimer
l'importance l'absence de ce texte n'est
pas une anecdote c'est quelque chose
d'important et je dirais même d'assez
grave en réalité
je ne m'étends pas salut chante du
réalisme des prévisions les dépenses et
des recettes présentées dans le PLFSS
comme j'ai déjà indiqué le gouvernement
la transmis au HCP que les impacts de la
réforme des retraites concernant les
2023 nos constats sont les suivants les
conséquences du projet de réforme des
retraites sur les financiers en 2023
sont faibles avec un coût estimé par le
gouvernement
04 milliards d'euros une estimation que
nous jouions réaliste ce cool la réforme
sur l'année 2023 résulte d'une part des
économies réalisées par le décalage de
trois mois du départ retraite d'environ
50000 personnes en fin d'année 2023 des
recettes fiscales et de cotisation
sociale supplémentaires liées à leur
maintien dans l'emploi pendant ces trois
mois ça ce sont pour les recettes et
d'autre part des dépenses
supplémentaires entraînées par la
réforme
c'est dépenses sont notamment la hausse
du minimum contributif dont les
conditions précises restent toutefois
déterminées des mesures sur la
pénibilité et l'usure professionnelle
des mesures en faveur des transitions
emplois retraite pour le dire simplement
sur 2023 les dépenses vont un peu plus
vite que les retours les recettes ou les
moindres des portes plus largement
s'agissant du solde prévu à 5 points de
piment en 2023 vous vous souvenez
peut-être que le HFP avait estimé en
septembre qu'il existait des risques que
le déficit pour 2023 soit plus dégradé
que prévu à ce jour ce risque il y a une
croissance plus faible et nous
maintenant que la croissance pourrait
être plus faible et contrebalancer par
la baisse récente des prix de gros du
gaz électricité qui elle si elle se
confirme pour être alléger le coût de
l'ensemble de dispositifs de soutien au
ménage et aux entreprises et donc il
n'est pas exclu qu'on soit à 5%
peut-être un peu moins peut-être un peu
plus en tout cas nous corrigeons un peu
notre appréciation ou vu
plutôt des bonnes nouvelles ce qu'on
appelle les winfool games en anglais
s'agissant des impacts de plus long
terme sur les finances publiques qui
sont le cœur de la réforme des retraites
le HCP n'a pas eu d'information
suffisante pour lui permettre d'évaluer
l'incidence de la réforme à moyen terme
tout au plus avons-nous reçu l'annexe au
belf RSS portant sur la période 2023
je le redis c'est tout à faire gretable
c'est aussi très difficile à comprendre
alors que nos finances publiques ont
plus que jamais besoin d'une gouvernance
transparente et d'une expertise
indépendante qui n'est pas qu'une
expertise puisque nous sommes une
institution prévue par la loi organique
de 2012 toutefois même en l'absence de
ces informations nous faisons un
diagnostic qui je crois n'est pas
négligeable qui est que la réforme des
retraites dans ce pffs ne devrait pas
améliorer la trajectoire de dette qui
avait présenté le gouvernement dans le
projet de FFP en septembre
elle ne témoigne en vérité d'aucune
ambition supplémentaire dans l'effort de
redressement des dépenses publiques
alors que selon la vie de septembre du
HCP la trajectoire présentée dans le
projet blood programmation était peu
ambitieuse en effet la flexion visait la
trajectoire de dette était limitée et
tardive
la dette
amorçait sa décrit en 2027 alors même
que les prothèses de croissance était
quant à elle plutôt optimiste cette
trajectoire impliquait d'ores et déjà
une réforme de retraite dans le projet
du gouvernement dont le Fcfp n'avait pas
eu les détails les données fournies au
Conseil permettent de constater que les
déficits des régimes de base de la
sécurité sociale du FSC sur la carte
2023-2006 sur désormais un peu plus
élevés un peu plus élevé que dans la
flss LFSS initiale pour 2023 les
dépenses de retraite progressent dans le
présent projet de loi plus rapidement
que prévu en septembre une telle
évolution et le résultat de
l'intégration de la réforme des
retraites dans la vente de retraite ne
mesure qui n'étaient pas encore
envisagées lors de la présentation du
projet de LPFP qui entraîne une légère
dégradation des comptes publics par
rapport à ce qui était prévu
donc voilà ça c'est quand même pas
d'inflexion de la trajectoire de dette
significative à attendre je voudrais
enfin terminer sur l'importance je ne
dis pas de là ça ce n'est pas mon sujet
mais d'une réforme des retraites il ne
revient pas au président du hcfp que je
suis pas davantage qu'au président de la
Cour des comptes que je suis également
dans des familles le contenu les
contours le calendrier les modalités
d'accompagnement de compensation tout ça
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
et du Parlement en lien avec les
partenaires sociaux
mais notre message là parle pour le coup
je suis dans mon rôle c'est dire qu'en
France le statu quo ne permettrait pas
de garantir la soutenabilité de nos
finances publiques il y a un problème de
son invité des finances publiques et il
y a un problème aussi de soutenabilité
du financement d'origine de retraite
notre rôle
c'est pas encore une fois faire de la
politique c'est de vous présenter l'état
de nos finances publiques qui ont connu
une dégradation sur une longue période
qui n'ont pas aujourd'hui les marches de
manœuvre pour faire face aux chocs et
aux investissements publics dans le pays
a besoin je ne veux pas jouer les
Cassandre d'autres l'ont fait et on les
entend plus beaucoup mais nous avons
bien quand même à la fois une montagne
d'investissement à financer et un mur de
dette
si les deux se font face ça ne va pas il
faut donc organiser un moment donné un
système de base communicant et retrouver
des marges de manœuvre sur la dette pour
financer les investissements sans quoi
c'est pas comment on fait laissez-moi
seulement rappeler quelques éléments
factuels la France est entrée dans la
zone euro car ratio de dettes dans la
moyenne européenne équivalent celui de
l'Allemagne c'était en 2000
2001 58 points de pivot 20 ans plus tard
notre position relative c'est nettement
dégradée la dette de la Belgique qui
était très élevée augmentée d'un point
la dette de l'Allemagne augmentait de 10
points la dette de l'Italie donc
beaucoup de gens
ce titre d'ailleurs estime qu'elle est
beaucoup trop élevée de 41 points la
dette de la France a augmenté de 55
points
un point 10 points 41 points 55 or cette
dette n'est plus gratuite nous sommes
sortis mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs clairement de l'ère des taux
d'intérêt négatifs le taux d'intérêt à
10 ans à retrouver son niveau
d'il y a 10 ans justement et alors que
la charge de la dette en comptabilité
nationale représentait 30 milliards en
2020 35 milliards en 2021 elle est
projetée déjà 44 milliards d'euros par
le gouvernement 2023 et nous savons que
le mouvement de haussetto n'est pas
arrêté que l'inflation n'est pas non
plus stoppée
or je l'ai déjà dit je te le dis depuis
des décennies en vérité il n'y a pas de
dépenses plus stérile et plus stupide
que la charge de la dette toute euro
qu'on consacre à rembourser la dette est
un euro en moins pour n'importe quelle
politique publique utile
pourquoi est-ce un tel problème parce
que la France fait face je l'ai dit à
des besoins d'investissement public
majeurs aujourd'hui faut pas s'y tromper
c'est aujourd'hui et non demain que la
France doit rénover son système de santé
qu'elle doit rénover son système
scolaire qu'elle doit financer
ses dépenses militaires qu'elle doit
produire sur son territoire des biens
essentiels qu'elle doit investir dans la
recherche et développement pour se
maintenir de la compétition mondiale et
nous sommes très clairement en train de
décrocher sur toute une série de
secteurs par exemple en matière de santé
nous levons infestir dans les
infrastructures pour nous adapter au
changement climatique et réduire
ces missions de CO2 donc je ne dis pas
qu'il n'y a pas de dépenses à faire il y
en a beaucoup mais si on n'a pas
d'argent pour le faire et qu'on est déjà
endetté et qu'on passe son temps à
rembourser la dette comment fait-on je
ne sais pas et donc je le dis clairement
je ne crois pas que l'État et la
dynamique de nos finances publiques
permettent de répondre à ces défis
réformer les retraites fait partie de
l'effort collectif à entreprendre mais
je termine par là madame et messieurs
les sénateurs ça ne suffira pas la
France a aussi la capacité la nécessité
d'améliorer ses comptes publics dans
tous les secteurs des politiques
publiques en recherchant j'insiste sur
ce mot la qualité de la dépense publique
ce qui n'est pas chose facile et
pourtant de nombreux pays ont procédé
avec succès dans cet exercice c'est ce
qu'on appelle les revues de dépenses
j'ai vu que le ministre des Finances
l'avaient annoncé il a raison c'est
nécessaire il a invité à des assises de
finances publiques la Cour des comptes
et le Conseil y participeront mais si on
fait de telles revues dépenses il faut
lui donner une gouvernance une raison
d'être un calendrier une méthode des
objectifs clairs
ça doit pas être une grand-messe ça doit
être un exercice continue et profond les
défis du temps j'en finis par là nous
appelle à la fois l'ambition nécessaire
mais aussi au sérieux et c'est vrai en
matière budgétaire
souvenons que il y a peu de moi un de
nos voisins qui certes n'est pas dans la
zone euro et c'était plus compliqué pour
lui la Grande-Bretagne
a connu des tensions sur sa dette
inattendues et ça nous montre qu'il faut
agir aujourd'hui et non demain sinon on
s'expose au risque qu'un beau jour
plutôt un mauvais jour sous pression
arrive à l'accident c'est le moment où
il faut couper drastiquement dans les
dépenses ou relever brutalement les
impôts et je crois qu'il ne faut faire
ni l'un ni l'autre rien de tout cela ne
serait dans l'intérêt de notre pays
voilà pourquoi il faut anticiper traiter
maintenant la question de la dette et
améliorer la qualité de notre dépense
publique
une réforme des retraites encore une
fois à vous de la déterminer on fait
partie voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les principales observations
du Haut conseil que je souhaitais
partager avec vous ce matin merci de
votre attention je me tiens à votre
disposition avec en effet l'équipe qui
m'entoure qui fait toujours un travail
remarquable en très peu de temps sous
grosse pression pour répondre à vos
questions
merci monsieur le Président voilà nous
démarrons bien l'année
n'est pas bien cette journée avec ce
tableau réaliste
de nos finances publiques je vais passer
la parole à rapporteur général Isabelle
Doisneau
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président pour vos propos
qui sont très claires et qui nous
amènent effectivement au pied du mur
comme je le dites je voudrais vous
souhaiter une très très bonne année bien
sûr ainsi l'ensemble de votre équipe et
vous remercier d'être à vous que vous
menez les uns les autres pour nous
éclairer sur ce chemin difficile de
choix politiques sérieux et
en total
ces raccord avec
roaccord avec les éléments dont nous
disposons les uns les autres et qui
parfois sont pas suffisants comme vous
avez pu le dire
c'est vrai que nous aurions souhaité les
uns les autres à voir ce collectif
social déjà les années précédentes là où
on a eu des décisions importantes à
prendre sur des dépenses
énormes or nous ne les avons pas eu ni
en 2020 ni en 2021 ni en 2022 et là il
se trouve que aujourd'hui on vous
retrouve donc c'est un quelque sorte un
certain paradoxe
de travailler sur un PLF RSS c'est vrai
vous aussi je le dirai qu'une seule fois
parce que c'est vraiment la barbare
qu'on pourra comment
admettre les uns et les autres alors je
vais me limiter en fait à trois
questions parce que je pense qu'il faut
laisser aussi à nos collègues le loisirs
de s'exprimer et j'ai à mes côtés en
plus René Paul Savary qui est notre
référent sur les retraites et qui sera
aussi
comment aller sur les questions les plus
essentielles sur un plan très
conjoncturel le Haut Conseil considère
que que la prévision de croissance du
gouvernement reste élevé c'est ce que
vous avez dit
qu'elle est en tout cas optimiste c'est
le terme que vous avez employé je relève
que que le mouvement social lié à la
réforme des retraites elle-même ne
figure pas parmi les facteurs de risque
or nous le voyons bien chaque jour les
annonces sont de plus en plus
importantes de grève par-ci de greffe
par là blocage par ciblocage par là et
ça ça peut plomber l'économie et il en
est il manque question dans votre dans
vos propos est-ce que vous pensez que
vous considérez que d'éventuelles grève
et blocage ne devrait pas avoir que peu
d'impact d'un point de vue économique
c'est la question ma deuxième question a
plus long terme comment le Haut Conseil
apprécit-il le caractère réaliste de la
trajectoire financière pluriannuelle de
la branche vieillesse au vu de la
réforme proposée avec les limites que
vous avez indiquées en complément y
a-t-il selon vous une marge pour l'ajout
de mesure généreuses que nous pourrions
les uns et les autres imaginer
en comment on avançant dans cet examen
de ce projet de loi donc de mesures
généreuses ou d'athénomation de la
réforme en cours de navette pour
parvenir à un objectif bien sûr
d'équilibre
la troisième la dernière question enfin
à la frontière de vos compétences de
Premier président de la Cour des comptes
considérez-vous opportun de jouer sur le
levier de la solidarité inter-branche en
particulier avec la branche ATMP et je
parle sous le torité de notre collègue
qui s'occupe de la branche TNT Pascal
grunis est-ce que vous pensez que donc
c'est c'est nécessaire et et intelligent
pour boucler le financement de la
réforme ou cela constitue-t-il une forme
de dévoiement en tout cas voilà pour mes
questions je dirais simplement que comme
vous monsieur le Président je suis assez
comment
inquiète c'est anxieuse sur la réaction
des Français par rapport à cette réforme
parce que je crois qu'on laisse trop de
dettes aux générations qui viennent vous
avez parlé d'une montagne
d'investissement mais vous avez énuméré
toutes les questions tous les sujets
sérieux que nous devrions ré aborder ou
aborder avec en conscience avec beaucoup
beaucoup de d'attention ce sont donc des
dépenses et puis il y a cette dette bref
on laisse les factures à nos enfants et
c'est terrible merci
on va prendre peut-être les questions de
René Paul ça varie et ensuite on sera
monsieur président oui merci je me
soucie bien sûr à l'intérêt de ce
rapport
simplement
on voit que la trajectoire du
gouvernement est fondée sur un scénario
1% de productivité 4 et demi de chômage
et que c'est comme ça qu'on estime le
déficit en 2070 aux alentours 13-14
milliards mais si on a un taux de
chômage à 7% rien que là on tombe à 19
milliards donc pensez-vous que cette
trajectoire est bonne et ou optimiste et
un deuxième point la réforme qui est une
réforme pour équilibrer les comptes nous
semble-t-il en 2070 du régime de
retraite montre que même si c'est
équilibré il y aura encore des déficits
importants même pour le régime général
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
inquiétant et quand on voit l'évolution
du système par répartition le fait de
prendre des mesures d'équilibre
régulièrement est-ce que il y a un taux
de natalité qui baisse de plus en plus
un nombre de cotisants qui diminue par
rapport au nombre de retraités un délai
de une durée de retraite qui est de plus
en plus longue pensez-vous que le
système par répartition peut un jour
être remis en cause et on remarques de
rapporteur général à savoir l'impact des
grèves sur l'économie qui n'a pas
semble-t-il été pris en compte il y a
peut-être un autre élément qui a pas été
pris en compte pour
l'Impact en 2023 que j'ai découvert
suite à une discussion avec l'argile
Carco c'est qu'il y a un nombre de
liquidation des retraites notamment de
ceux qui étaient en surcotte qui vont
pouvoir partir et qui en fait compte
tenu des incertitudes de la réforme
depuis qu'elle est annoncée depuis deux
trois mois liquide leur retraite alors
qu'ils ne l'avait pas
forcément
envisagé ce qui fait qu'ils ont un
nombre de dossiers de liquidation
beaucoup beaucoup plus important que
ceux qui connaissent habituellement ce
qui voudrait dire que derrière il y a
déjà un impact éventuellement financier
par des gens qui prennent leur retraite
par anticipation par rapport à leur
prévision qui risque d'annuler un peu
les effets de la réforme des 2023 qu'en
pensez-vous merci voilà monsieur le
président
je m'en excuse décevoir le rapporteur
général monsieur le sénateur parce que
je suis ici en qualité de président du
hcfp et non pas comme un premier
président de la Cour des comptes je vais
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
notamment un chapitre introductif sur
les finances publiques dans le prochain
rapport public annuel que je rendrai au
président de la République et au
Parlement le 15 mars prochain mais
je ne serai pas fâché d'entrer dans ce
débat mais en tant que président du HCP
j'ai une compétence limitée vous me
pardonnerez de m'y tenir de ne pas
spéculer trop d'autant que je le redis
nous avons en fait très peu d'éléments
et c'est sur quoi je voulais assister
vous m'interrogez au fond sur les
scénarios d'une part et d'abord sur
l'impact à moyen terme de la réforme des
retraites
c'est vrai que mais là je m'en tiens
des informations rendues publiques
les dispositions du PLFSS conduit à
réduire le défi de 13 milliards en 2030
projette pas au-delà le déficit public
baisserait donc d'environ 0,4 points de
PIB toutes choses égales par ailleurs à
cet horizon 2030 donc bien au-delà de
l'horizon de la lqfp qui n'existe pas
mais comme nous l'avons indiqué les
informations transmises au Conseil ne
lui ont pas permis d'évaluer l'incidence
de moyen terme de la réforme des
retraites sur les finances publiques
notamment son effet sur les dépenses
publiques le gouvernement n'a par
exemple pas fourni d'éléments sur le
nombre de personnes qui devront décaler
leur départ ni sur le montant de
retraite alors la force sur une pas sur
ceux qui anticipent ou sur les
comportements peuvent voir ici là en
outre le chiffrage vraiment de prendre
en compte que les effets mécaniques des
mesures annoncées ne tient pas compte
tes dépenses supplémentaires annoncées
d'invalidité d'indemnités journalières
tu as mis des chômage
qui devrait découler du maintien sur le
marché de travail de salariés à
l'inverse il ne tient pas compte du
surcroît de recette du à la hausse des
taux d'emploi aux âges élevés je crois
de production résultant en tout état de
cause je m'en tiens à ça le gain dégagé
par la forme des retraites ne suffira
pas à lui seul je l'ai dit à restaurer
des marges de manœuvre suffisantes ça
c'est absolument clair
vous m'avez interrogé madame le
rapporteur général
sur sur les les grèves
d'abord c'est pas tout à fait notre
métier que mesurer cet impact disons que
il y a toujours un impact qui est à
court terme
mais en général peu élevé sur les
finances publiques par exemple les coûts
du conflit de 1995 qui n'a pas été dans
mon souvenir le plus léger mettez le
plus dur ont été d'environ zéro un point
de PIB donc relativement négligeable en
général c'est un effet de court terme
qui est rattrapé ensuite et notons que
depuis 1995 les différents effets de
législation et autres font que ces coups
ont tendance à se limiter et que les
mouvements sociaux s'organisent
autrement donc pour être hors de ma zone
de confort mais quand même m'engager un
peu je pense qu'il était sont très
limitées s'il y en a c'est pas ça qu'il
faut craindre
économiquement je pense pour le reste je
lui dis je n'ai pas de suffisamment
d'informations pour vous répondre madame
la rapporteur de manière pertinente sur
les marges de manœuvre dont disposons
puisque n'ayant pas d'impact à moyen
terme je peux pas vous dire à fortiori
ce que sont les démarches disponibles
désolé d'être aussi lacunaire mais
je le suis à mesure des informations
dont je dispose et encore une fois je ne
voudrais pas sortir de mon rôle ici de
prison du hcfp et m'engager comme ça sur
des débats très importants en matière de
protection sociale sur lesquels elle
court et compétente mais elle est passée
dire en l'occurrence
alors nous allons prendre
la question et ensuite nous aurons trois
autres commissaires Raymond de pensée
mange Bernard Chemillé qui était pour ce
poly Monique Lubin vraiment de penser
oui merci
monsieur le Président écoutez
nous regrettons avec vous le caractère
incomplète des éléments qui vous ont été
transmis par le gouvernement et qui ne
vous permet pas donc d'évaluer l'impact
à moyen terme de la réforme donc nous
naviguons à vue par rapport à ce rapport
mais la première chose que je voulais
dire c'est c'est vrai que vous êtes tenu
à l'impact sur la sur le système des
retraites c'est normal mais vous n'avez
pas élargi l'étude des impacts de la
réforme en dehors du système des
retraites en mesurant notamment les
dépenses supplémentaires sur le chômage
ou sur le RSA qui vont être induite
puisque le corps indique le report de 62
à 64 implique une hausse des dépenses en
termes de prestation sociale hors
retraite de 3,9 milliards alors c'était
peut-être pas votre commande mais c'est
vrai que c'est un volant qui est un peu
un point aveugle de votre rapport et ma
question est celle là vous estimez à 50
000 personnes sur un quadrimestre donc
il faudrait presque multiplier par 3 si
on veut voir les générations suivantes
mais 50 000 personnes sur la
quadrimestre de cette année qui seront
donc décalés dans leur dans leur prise
enfin dans le départ à 900 ce qui a été
dit c'est qu'effectivement les personnes
qui n'ont plus de surcotte vont
peut-être liquider avant puisque quand
même le mécanisme des surcotes étaient
crasés par cette réforme donc parmi ces
50000 personnes comme vous avez calculé
les recettes induites de par leur
cotisation ou les économies de par le
fait qu'ils moi j'aimerais savoir et
vous devez le savoir comment vous
pouviez pas calculer combien était en
emploi combien étaient déjà en chemin
enfin était en emploi combien était en
chômage et combien était en ligne
inactivité ce qu'on appelle les ni en
emploi ni en retraite je vous remercie
Bernard jaumier merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
pour votre exposé
vous avez
longuement insisté sur la nécessité
d'avoir une loi de programmation des
finances publiques alors pour discuter
un peu de ce point vous interrogez on
est quand même une loi politique la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
donc pardon de vous entraîner sur ce
terrain là mais un des un des débats que
nous avons tenté d'avoir avec le
gouvernement porte sur la structure de
la dépense publique vous avez relevé que
elle a augmenté qu'il y a des
investissements lourds auxquels procéder
or quand on analyse cette dépense
publique sur les dernières décennies le
financement de notre service public la
part relative du financement de nos
services publics c'est réduite et nous
avons des services publics y compris des
fonctions régaliennes de l'État comme la
justice qui sont en grande difficulté
nos infrastructures ferroviaires ne sont
pas particulièrement en bon état etc
et nous avons augmenté par contre très
fortement
les transferts vers les entreprises et
vers les ménages et nous avons tenté de
poser ce débat lors de la dernière loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
parce que le Conseil d'analysé
économique lui-même pointe le fait que
certains transferts vers les entreprises
ont une utilité démontrée sur l'emploi
mais d'autres le Conseil les qualifie
d'inefficace et pourtant il n'est pas
possible de mener ce débat le
gouvernement ferme la porte à toute
évolution en la matière alors il est
compliqué pour des assemblées qui sont
des assemblées politiques
d'approuver y compris par des compromis
une loi de programmation des finances
publiques s'il n'est pas possible de
discuter de la structure de la dépense
publique vous en conviendrez et la
deuxième question que je voulais vous
poser et au regard des dépenses en
termes de compétitivité qui ont été
importantes dans notre pays qui
notamment consiste pour une partie aux
exonérations en direction des
entreprises on constate que sur deux
décennies le commerce extérieur ne se
porte pas mieux que la
réindustrialisation du pays
on va dire est très faible voilà il y a
eu un légère un léger mouvement on va
dire depuis deux ans mais c'est un
phénomène qui reste est faible et que
par ailleurs cette politique là a eu à
des impacts climatiques qui maintenant
sont relevés et je ne parle pas des
impacts sur la souveraineté de notre
pays au fond est-ce qu'il faut
poursuivre dans cette direction
merci Katia pour soupe
je vous remercie bien tout d'abord
vous disiez dans votre propos que les
finances publiques avaient besoin de
transparence
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
évidemment mais je pense que nous en
sommes malheureusement très loin alors
moi j'ai deux questions
ne pensez vous pas que les 2 milliards
d'euros d'exonération donc de
cotisations retraite aux employeurs ne
devraient pas être minima compensé par
l'État chaque année ce qui n'est quand
même pas le cas et puis ma deuxième
question c'est sur la CNRACL la
revalorisation des pensions minimales à
1200 euros brut pas net mais brut va
impacter les collectivités qui ont
beaucoup d'agents il faut le dire en
catégorie C et vont devoir payer 800
millions d'euros
supplémentaires en raison donc de la
réforme du gouvernement alors que ces
collectivités pour l'instant ne seront
pas impactés ne seront pas compensés à
leur auprès sur l'augmentation du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires donc
il ne faudrait-il pas donc un mécanisme
par rapport donc à la revalorisation des
pensions minimales de compensation par
l'État ou collectivité territoriale je
vous remercie Monique Lebas
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président cette réforme nous a été
présentée comme la mère des réformes et
vous venez de confirmer qu'en fait au vu
en tout cas des éléments
insuffisants nous l'avons bien compris
qui sont votre possession
que cette réforme ne pourra avoir qu'un
effet finalement minime et en tout cas
qu'elle sera loin d'être suffisante pour
faire baisser à elle seule le niveau de
la dette vous insistez sur la nécessité
de maîtriser la dette ce dont personne
ne dis ce qu'on vient je pense mais
lorsqu'on parle de faire baisser la
dette on s'est immédiatement les baisses
de dépenses et vous précisez qu'il ne
serait ni opportun d'abaisser
drastiquement les dépenses ni opportun
donc monter les impôts bon
donc les marges de manoeuvre ressemblent
quand même assez réduite néanmoins
compte tenu du tableau que vous venez de
nous dresser
pensez-vous que les les baisses d'impôts
qui ont été considérables sur ces 5
dernières années et nous avons encore eu
sur le budget 2023 la fin de la de la
CVAE donc tous impôts confondus
pensez-vous que cette trajectoire puisse
durer éternellement
c'est le président première série de
questions
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
bon je redis que mes réponses notamment
sur la structure des recettes des
dépenses sociales les compensations sont
forcément limitées elles sont limitées
par les compétences qui sont les miennes
aujourd'hui en tant que président de la
SSP et encore plus limité par la nature
vraiment étroite des informations dont
je dispose et de la saisie néanmoins ce
que je peux dire c'est plusieurs choses
d'abord sur sur l'impact financier pour
2023 juridique il y avait un coup de 400
millions d'euros je redis parce que au
milieu de des différents messages que je
passais il y en a un qui n'est peut-être
pas passer c'est que nous estimons que
c'est réaliste ce coup de 400 millions
d'euros conduit d'informations dont nous
disposons alors après vous m'interrogez
sur le chômage supplémentaire parmi les
personnes pas la retraite à 60 61 ans
France stratégie à réaliser une
évaluation qui date un peu 18 où ils
estiment qu'il y a la moitié est en
activité
10% sur le chômage et un tiers sont en
gros inactives quant à l'estimation de
50000 personnes qui
décalent au départ la retraite en 2023
ce sont les personnes qui sont réforme
des retraites seraient parti dès lors 62
ans à partir de 1er octobre novembre
décembre sans la réforme qui devront
décaler au départ et environ 200 000
personnes par an en effet
quatre trimestres qui partent en
retraite dès l'âge légal atteints sur un
peu plus de 700 000 départs par an les
personnes qui comptaient partir à la
retraite dès lors 62 ans à partir du 1er
octobre novembre décembre et qui devront
représenter leur départ représente un
quart des personnes qui auraient pris la
retraite des 62 ans qui est donc environ
50000 personnes en effet là encore nous
estimons que cette mesure réaliste donc
si vous vous la projetez pour la suite
ça devrait être de l'ordre de 200 000 et
encore une fois nous n'avons pas nous
d'informations
de coin de table que nous avons été
amenés à faire sur les lois de
programmation des finances publiques
parce que vous savez quand tu es sorti
le proche de loi de financement le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques nous avons également
rendu un avis qui était assez critique
nous estimons que c'était pas si
ambitieux et que les hypothèses
sous-jacentes étaient de surcroît trop
positif néanmoins malgré cela de la même
façon que je me suis pas prononcé sur la
réforme des retraites c'est pas mon
travail
je me prononce sur l'ancienne d'une
programmation je le redis devant vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un impératif que de disposer d'une
loi de programmation de finance publique
c'est un impératif au regard de nos
règles internes l'eau conseil par
exemple doit travailler sur des écarts
de loi de programmation s'il y a pas
d'objectif de moyen terme nous
travaillons un peu son filet et donc nos
avis sont plus faibles or comme nous
sommes aussi un élément du bloc de
constitutionnalité tout ça rend les
choses quand même un peu gazeuses et
nous ne sommes pas à l'abri d'avoir à ce
moment-là un processus de finance
publique qui est d'abord mal éclairé
peut transparent et de plus discontinue
car nous pouvons pas baser par exemple
les bois de règlement sur des
informations fiables
c'est un vrai risque juridique c'est un
vrai risque juridique c'est pas à moi de
l'évaluer mais il existe chacun le sait
et le sous-estimé en remettant ça comme
la poussière sur le tapis n'est pas
prudent deuxièmement dans une autre vie
patience j'étais de l'autre côté de la
frontière belge à Bruxelles où j'étais
commissaire et en charge justement ces
problèmes de finances publiques
coup de chance en ce moment il y a pas
de règle des finances publiques
européenne qui souhaite opérationnelle
ou de chance
on va rétablir des règles et il le faut
par ailleurs car sans règle n'a pas de
boussole et pas d'encre
la Commission européenne a besoin
également d'une programmation de finance
publique pour fonder ses décisions
ces opinions
et donc à un moment donné elle pourrait
estimer que c'est un élément manquant
fondamental y compris pour la mise en
œuvre d'un certain nombre de financement
européen voilà la raison pour laquelle
sur un plan formel mais il est important
je me permets d'insister sur le fait que
l'absence de loi de programmation et
finance publique n'est pas une bricole
n'est pas une anecdote que c'est un
problème substantiel et assez
préoccupant après monsieur le sénateur
vous m'a poussé un peu plus loin je vais
quand même vous répondre parce que en
effet nous avons déjà eu l'occasion d'en
débattre sur ces sujets au sein du Haut
Conseil et comme à la Cour des comptes
nous avons quand même un vrai paradoxe
français c'est que nous avons
le plus haut niveau de dépenses
publiques de l'Union européenne avec le
Danemark quelques 58% du PIB et pourtant
nous observons une perception au moins
mais aussi parfois une réalité de
dégradation de la qualité de certains
services publics je rappelle que la Cour
des comptes avant l'élection
présidentielle en décembre 2021 avait
sorti toute une série de notes
structurels qui démontrait un certain
nombre de défaillances mais si je veux
en prendre deux exemples prenons
l'exemple de la politique du logement en
France qui est deux fois plus coûteuse
que la moyenne de l'Union européenne
juste deux fois plus coûteuse et qui
n'est pas jugé comme plus performante y
compris par rapport à son objectif
central qu'il délivrait des logements
sociaux
je ne plaide pas du tout pour couper par
deux les dépenses du logement mais on
voit bien qu'il y a un problème vous
l'avez dit vous-même monsieur le
sénateur d'efficacité
deuxièmement en matière d'éducation un
système éducatif puissant massif coûteux
dont les performances se dégradent ça
c'est les mesures bizarres de l'OCDE etc
ça prouve bien qu'il y a des problèmes
d'efficacité de la dépense publique
après il faut aller chercher ou vous
avez parlé des mesures de transfert
France stratégie estime que les mesures
de transfert vers les entreprises ont
plutôt un effet positif sur la
compétitivité mais je veux pas répondre
à la place de ce que je veux dire
simplement c'est que la nécessité
absolue c'est bel et bien celle de ses
revues de dépenses publiques il faut
soulever le capot la dépense publique et
des politiques publiques voir ce qui
marche ce qui ne marche pas retenir ce
qui marche le développer le musclé
investir et être capable aussi
d'économiser ou de maîtriser la dépense
sur ce qui ne fonctionne pas j'ai pas
toutes les réponses la Cour des comptes
participera ces exercices mais
c'est indispensable sinon on va entrer
dans un paradoxe vraiment très coûteux
un moment donné où nos compatriotes à la
fois se plaignent d'un excès de dépense
financé par des prélèvements
d'autres termes quelqu'un n'est pas les
dragons fiscal je sais pas si qui
s'était et de l'autre côté il peut y
avoir un effet ou les services publics
eux-mêmes sont perçus comme peu
fonctionnel et chacun peut en faire
l'expérience ça ne marche pas et pour
attraper ça il faut absolument améliorer
la qualité de notre dépense publique
voilà la finalité de l'exercice et quel
que soit après tout les préférences
politiques dans cette salle il y en a
qui sont différentes c'est normal c'est
le démocratie chacun doit y participer
personne ne peut satisfaire au niveau de
dépenses et tu ne faible qualité de
prestation ça me paraît quand même du
bon sens si le surcroît on est face à un
endettement massif et qu'on ne peut pas
financer ni l'existant ni l'avenir là on
se trouve quand même dans un nœud
gardien qui est quand même tout à fait
singulier enfin sur sur les baisses
d'impôts puisque la question m'a été
posée je ici redire un message que j'ai
exprimé à plusieurs reprises
en septembre que ce soit en tant que
président de la Cour des comptes ou en
tant que président du hcfp
si on doit et c'est le point de vue de
la Cour des comptes comme du HFP
maîtriser nos finances publiques donc
réduire nos déficits et notre dette
il y a finalement que trois voix
soit on fait de la croissance
il faut le faire il faut muscler la
croissance potentielle comme on dit mais
que personne ici ne nourrissent une
illusion nous ne sommes pas à l'aube de
Trente Glorieuses nous aurons dans les
années qui viennent des taux de
croissance qui seront limités limitées
donc n'ayons pas l'illusion de la
croissance magique la croissance vaille
pour voir non faisons le plus de
croissance possible et de toute façon ce
ne sont pas des années extraordinaires
qui nous attendent deuxième solution
on peut et il faut maîtriser les
dépenses
et la troisième c'est d'agir sur les
recettes or il y a un plafond
consentement la peau que nous constatons
tous chez nos concitoyens alors qu'ils
appartiennent au places populaires
couches moyennes
bon donc à un moment donné n'ayons pas
non plus l'illusion que les impôts vont
le faire
le message que délivrer la cour il était
très clair il a d'ailleurs été entendu
c'est que nous n'avons pas en l'état
dans les circonstances de croissance
faible
avec une dépense qui continue
d'augmenter nous n'avons pas les marges
de manœuvre pour faire des baisses
d'impôts sèches c'est le non compensé
soit par d'autres hausse d'impôts
soit par une maîtrise des dépenses a du
concurrence et donc nous l'avons dit ce
qui a été entendu par le gouvernement
qui en effet décidé d'étaler un certain
nombre de décision parce que sinon des
baisses à peau sèches n'auraient eu
qu'un seul effet qui aurait été creusé
le déficit ce que nous ne pouvons pas
nous permettre puisque nous avons déjà
des objectifs de finances publiques qui
sont beaucoup trop peu ambitieux voilà
je ne fais pas plus loin dans la
démonstration mais ça souligne encore
une fois l'impératif absolu et ça c'est
vraiment un message que je voudrais
faire partager d'une d'un travail
maintenant en profondeur sur la qualité
de la dépense publique pour réduire cet
écart entre la perception d'une
dégradation des services publics des
dépenses publiques qui restent très
élevées des prélèvements obligatoires
qui eux aussi sont très pesants pour nos
concitoyens tant qu'on ne sort pas de ça
alors on est quand même dans une aire
d'insatisfaction qu'on peut comprendre
mais je sors de mon rôle
donc je m'arrête
il est mouillé
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
président merci pour vos propos
j'ai un peu le sentiment vous écoutant
de de je me revois il y a quelques mois
lorsque nous avons déjà une analyse de
la situation du bénéfice et vous propose
des très proches avec beaucoup
d'interrogations sur
la pertinence des taux de croissance
affichées le volume des dépenses on
retrouve finalement le même discours au
regard d'une situation qui semble à peu
près équivalente même si il y a des
éléments nouveaux de réforme qui sont
proposés j'ai on a bien entendu aussi
que vous êtes dans un rôle qui reste
limité aujourd'hui puisque vous êtes sur
l'analyse finalement
de l'évolution de 2023 alors c'est vrai
que pour nous ça peut être frustration
parce que moi quand je suis ce matin
j'étais heureux de vous rencontrer de
vous entendre et de bénéficier de votre
savoir-faire autour de tout ça
alors ma question ma question est la
suivante puisque on a bien compris que
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez que nous
évoquer des grands principes généraux et
en tous les cas on a noté on a noté très
fortement avec un crayon les enjeux sur
la tout ce qui est programmation et s'il
y a d'ailleurs pour les finances
publiques comme dans d'autres politiques
publiques d'une façon générale moi j'ai
une question de réaction à votre
démonstration vous évoquez les
différents leviers la croissance les
économies les sons de la dette moi j'ai
une question très simple parce que vous
croyez d'une façon générale en lien avec
ces réformes des retraites que la notion
d'augmentation du temps de travail
que ça soit par l'augmentation de la
durée de travail dans la vie ou par
rapport l'augmentation générale stricte
du temps de travail regard à la fois de
votre positionnement de votre expérience
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible un levier essentiel qui
pourrait peut-être venir contrecarrer le
scénario extrêmement étroit que vous
évoquez comme étant une possible
démarche manœuvre voilà voilà ma
question
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président vous avez
précisé à juste titre que vous deviez
calibrer vos propos compte tenu de la
compétence qui est la vôtre ici
il n'empêche
la nature même de votre exposé nous
invite à nous poser les bonnes questions
et le fait d'entendre que
on a besoin d'éclairage de transparence
sur les dépenses publiques nous nous
alertes et vous n'en avez convaincu
enfin moi vous m'avez convaincu était
nécessaire que l'absence de loi de
programmation des finances publiques est
un risque juridique
mais je dirais que c'est aussi un risque
politique et c'est même un risque
démocratique
parce que on a au niveau de prélèvement
comme vous l'avez dit au niveau de dette
mais si c'était pour des investissements
de long terme et si c'était pour avoir
des services publics qui soient perçus
comme fonctionnant parfaitement et
rendant les services qui doivent rendre
je pense que nos concitoyens pourraient
l'accepter mais il se posent une
question terrible
à tous les niveaux un classe populaire
classement moyenne personne plus
favorisées c'est où va l'argent
cette question là on l'entend de plus en
plus alors elle paraît basique simple
mais je pense que elle nous elle nous
interpelle cette question qui sommes
responsables et donc
vous avez évoqué le niveau de dette qui
a progressé de 55 points pour la France
de de 41 points pour l'Italie mais
est-ce que
cette loi de programmation pourrait
aussi nous permettre d'avoir des
éléments comparatifs sur la structure de
nos dépenses les transferts les
investissements le fonctionnement des
services publics et pouvoir avoir des
des niveaux de comparaison avec les
autres pays européens comme vous en avez
vous en avez donné pour le niveau
d'endettement parce que moi même comme
rapporteur de la branche famille je suis
toujours étonné du manque de de
benchmark on peut avoir sur des
politiques essentielles comme la
politique familiale au moment où la
natalité est en berne par rapport à des
niveaux de comparaison sur d'autres
politique qui sont menées par les pays
européens je vous remercie
Daniel
merci madame
la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président pour pour vos propos
vous nous avez rappelé effectivement que
la dette de la France et de l'Allemagne
par rapport au PIB et la même en 2000
et qu'elle a augmenté depuis combien de
le dire Olivier de 55 points et l'Italie
40 la Belgique hein ça veut dire que il
y a eu des efforts plus importants dans
d'autres pays que nous pour maîtriser la
dette et en fait vous l'avez dit la
charge de la dette était de 30 milliards
en 2020 et va passer bientôt à 40 ou 50
milliards c'est à dire qu'en fait plus
on empruntait finalement on gagnait en
empruntant mais on a changé complètement
tout cela avec les difficultés la guerre
en Ukraine et l'inflation donc si vous
voulez vous nous avez également dit que
bien on avait des dépenses générales en
France plus importante pour au niveau
public et pense publique plus importante
et que fallait trouver les moyens de
maîtriser les dépenses d'être plus
efficace effectivement dans les dans les
services publics mais
on voit que le Président de la
République nous dit que il faut
augmenter
ajuste titre sûrement le budget des
armées il faut augmenter aussi dans la
santé on voit bien et dans dans
l'éducation enfin voilà alors si vous
voulez
qu'est-ce qui y reste et à maîtriser les
dépenses à mieux orienter les dépenses
mais pour avoir
pour maîtriser la dette ne faut-il pas
avoir plus de recettes c'est à dire que
faire on a faire un petit peu ce qu'a
fait l'Allemagne en 2000 c'est-à-dire
réindustrialiser le pays pour avoir plus
de retraite nous pour avoir plus de
recettes vous nous avez dit que les
retraites bon vont pas apporter
énormément mais c'est quand même pas mal
d'équilibrer un budget puisque le budget
des retraites fait partie aussi de la
sécurité sociale donc ne faut-il pas pas
avoir une loi de programmation pour la
réindustrie réalisation du pays pour que
on est plus de plus de recettes pour
d'abord équilibrer notre budget ne plus
faire d'elle et après progressivement
essayer de rembourser des dettes pour ne
pas aller complètement dans le mur
pour terminer Florence ça Sarrade et
Freder Florence merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président moi
j'ai une question de détails à vous
poser un exemple comme quoi l'état
ferait mieux de faire de la pédagogie
plutôt que de la démagogie je m'explique
les le cumul emploi retraite des des
médecins étaient limité par le fait que
les médecins devaient continuer à payer
leur cotisations retraite on a décidé
enfin d'ensemble que finalement ces
cotisations retraite ils allaient en
être exonérés or c'est finalement la
caisse de retraite des médecins qui paye
la différence résultat elle n'augmente
pas les les pensions de ces
médecins finalement l'opération est
nulle pour l'État en coût mais par
contre au point du confiance dans le
système et adhésion des des
médecins dans l'exemple donné à ses
possibilités de de réforme de retraite
catastrophique est-ce que ça va être
pareil à tout niveau
et pour terminer Frédéric oui merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président une question un peu rapide moi
j'entends les enjeux la nécessité et je
pense que vous vous avez déjà un public
un peu convaincu dans la salle d'une loi
de programmation des défenses publiques
j'entends que pour qu'elle soit
acceptable elle doit s'inscrire dans le
temps et qu'elle doit nécessairement
faire preuve d'une analyse à court et à
moyen et à long terme et si je reprends
les propos de de Monique Lubin qui les
reprend aussi au président de la
République si cette réforme est la mère
des retraites qu'elle nécessite aussi
qu'il y ait un peu de pédagogie qui soit
faite qu'elle nécessite nécessairement
qu'on s'inscrive dans le dans le cours
dans le moyen et dans le long terme
comment expliquer vous le caractère
incomplet des informations qui vont être
transmises et qui ne nous permettent pas
à nous parlementaires de faire preuve de
pédagogie de nous inscrire dans le moyen
de le long terme
monsieur le président
j'ai toujours plaisir monsieur le
sénateur à venir parmi vous retrouvez
même avec des informations lacunaires et
un mandat réduit
on peut quand même dire un certain
nombre de choses et avoir un centre de
débat il y en a d'autres que je n'ai pas
pouvoir
entreprendre par exemple le slogan plus
de pédagogie moins démagogie pas pouvoir
être assez consensuel parmi vous je peux
en revanche pas tout à fait développer
là la question qui était posée j'ai pas
répondu sur la mère des réformes mais
moi je vais quand même tenter de percer
la première c'est que
mère des réformes
mais cette réforme ne suffira pas à
équilibrer nos finances publiques
on le sait et deuxièmement si c'est une
mère elle aura des enfants parce que ce
ne sera pas la dernière réforme question
ça se sont deux de choses que nous
savons puisque même dans les
calculs qui sont rendus publics on sait
qu'au-delà de 2030
il y aura quand même d'autres exercices
à reprendre je ferme cette parenthèse il
y a deux questions auxquelles trois
questions auxquelles je peux vous
répondre la première c'est sur la
question du temps de travail et je vais
livrer deux réflexions la première c'est
que nous savons quand même que la durée
de travail est un facteur de croissance
chez dans cette évidence le travail du
capital l'innovation sont des facteurs
de croissance mais
ayant dit ça il est évident aussi que
l'arbitrage entre temps de travail tant
de loisirs temps de la vie et
profondément un choix politique que
chacun d'entre nous peut aborder par
certains regards la deuxième chose c'est
que s'agissant d'une réforme des
retraites on sait bien que si on
considère c'est une prémisse qui peut
être discutée mais la Cour est
clairement du côté de la nécessité d'une
réforme parce que nous pensons que le
système tel qu'il est n'est pas
finançable
si on a un besoin de financement
les ressources vous les connaissez c'est
l'augmentation des cotisations
c'est la dégradation des pensions ou
c'est l'augmentation de la durée de
travail alors après la forme est-ce que
c'est l'âge légal est-ce que c'est pas
du tout mon rayon mais
je me pose sur un point de vue et
financier il y a ces trois leviers et
nous nous sommes prononcés à plusieurs
reprises en disant que en effet il
fallait tout de même que ce soit le
temps de travail sur la durée de la vie
qui soit un peu plus long ce qui est
aussi un facteur macroéconomique encore
une fois je le dis sans me prononcer en
quoi que ce soit sur les modalités de la
réforme c'est vous mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs en lien avec le
gouvernement les partenaires sociaux
c'est ça la démocratie nous sommes une
institution experte et qui délivre des
avis importants mais nous ne sommes pas
à votre place j'ai trop fait de
politique je respecte trop le politique
pour vouloir lui donner la moindre le
soi-même si j'ai quelques mémoires en
effet monsieur le sénateur puisqu'en
2001 il se trouve qu'au moment du
passage à l'euro je t'aime ministre des
états européennes ça me rajeunit pas je
l'étais même déjà depuis un certain
nombre d'années j'avais été jeune
ministre il est vrai et c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque on parlait souvenons-nous de
l'Allemagne comme de l'homme malade de
l'Europe étant un peu changé si on
regarde en effet les performances de
notre commerce extérieur les
performances de notre industrie les
performances de nos finances publiques
il y a quand même je crois que quelques
sujets de réflexion collectif puisque
depuis lors on a quand même essayé pas
mal de formes politiques dans notre pays
on a changé assez souvent de président
de formation dominante etc et on a une
certaine continuité donc encore une fois
je crois que les interrogations sur nos
finances publiques elles sont pour
maintenant sur notre industrie également
mais au-delà de cette remarque très
générale je voudrais faire plus
particulière sur la sur la dette
dans une autre vie aussi j'ai été mise
et finances c'était une époque où
c'était en pleine crise financière Chris
grecque et la dette publique la charge
de la dette est-elle le deuxième budget
de l'État je ne souhaite pas à mon pire
ennemi de venir miserance dans ces
conditions parce que vous n'avez pas la
moindre marge de manœuvre pour faire
quoi que ce soit or
nous en approchons le budget de la
défense c'est 41 milliards d'euros
hors pension avec les pensions c'est 50
milliards d'euros il va sans doute être
évalué par la loi de programmation
militaire mais il faut trouver les
moyens de la financer cette loi de
programmation militaire
et la charge de la dette s'est dit
pourrait atteindre 44 milliards d'euros
le jour où vous avez quand même la
charge de la dette comme le deuxième
budget de l'État
c'est vraiment c'est la dépense publique
c'est la plus stupide la plus inerte la
plus introductive la plus inefficace la
plus absurde c'est-à-dire que chaque
euro vous allez consacrer à rembourser
la dette que nous allons rembourser
collectivement rembourser la dette est
un euro en moins pour les préférences de
chacun pour
du travail pour de la justice pour de la
sécurité pour de l'écologie pour de
l'éducation pour de la recherche
vraiment je crois que c'est un sujet
certains semblent avoir une préférence
pour la dette ça n'a pas de sens
non la dette est vraiment la dépense
publique qui stérilise tout et nous
entrons car nous sommes sortis de la
période des taux d'intérêt négatif dans
une période où
la charge de la dette augmente elle
augmente à la fois on le sait du fait du
poids des obligations à l'excès
inflation et pour l'instant nous avons
encore une inflexion
d'intérêt dont nous savons qu'elle ne va
pas s'arrêter madame Lagarde il y a
encore deux jours à expliquer que quand
une situation de l'inflation en Europe
il y aurait des hausses de taux
d'intérêt substantiels je la cite c'est
une réflexion quand même que nous devons
vraiment je crois avoir doux encore une
fois la nécessité en effet de disposer
d'une loi de programmation de finance
publique et je termine par là tout à
fait d'accord avec vous monsieur le
sénateur c'est une question juridique je
soulève les obstacles juridiques parce
qu'à un moment donné ça coince quand
même c'est à dire que je ne pense pas
que c'est une simple formalité qu'on
peut vivre sans non non un moment donné
on est rattrapé par la patrouille je
sais pas quand je sais pas comment mais
je vois quand même arriver un vrai sujet
mais
l'ayant dit vous avez raison sur le fait
que c'était aussi un sujet politique et
démocratique qu'il faut éclairer nos
concitoyens aussi sur la structure des
dépenses et des recettes que la lol
d'ailleurs en fait maintenant
l'obligation dans sa nouvelle formule
davantage au gouvernement bon c'est
aussi un des rôles de la Cour des
comptes je sors de mon rôle le président
aujourd'hui que de contribuer par ses
rapports à apporter un certain nombre
d'éclairages et on trouve dans nos
travaux aussi un certain nombre de
d'informations c'est notre fierté que de
les délivrer c'est notre plaisir c'est
Monsieur le sénateurs quand vous nous le
demandez en l'occurrence comme vous me
le demandez puisque je suis le
porte-parole de cette institution en
quelque sorte que nous avons présenté
ces travaux ce que je referais bien
volontiers soit comme président de au
Conseil des finances publiques soit